foreign we're talking about 26 and other numbers
you were previously he had uh no idea very nice
here's Waldman as the preseason for Detroit
is underway this is the third game for the
Pittsburgh Penguins a couple split squads against
the Columbus Blue Jacket that's Vinnie in astrosa
turning with it played two seasons with Alex
to break it to Chicago he gets tied up by cider
boy cider was giving it out of training camp
wasn't he physical there's a shot to score that
was set up you beautifully from in behind the net
very pretty set up there from valtteri pustenance
the other side it's like whoa top Corner
nice to be done altered two [Music] that's
basically going back to where you came from hit
on Jonathan Gruden save their mind and dalkovich
here Olivier Joseph number 73 on the
fence for the Penguins couldn't come
up with it the Red Wings do buy while
Linder number 54 good stutter stepped
there by Costa threw it in down low and a
save there by nadelkovic off Dylan Larkin
and by Raymond racing after I guess
he missed it and that'll come back as
an icing charge against Detroit and Redwing
Allman's taking in he's got it hold it back
Allman and Lawson Edge what a play though
to Larkin and a save there fine adelkovic
there's too many men penalty it
looks like I think too many men but
Too Many Men and then flip before could settle for
Raymond says Jake Wallman one more time for Petrie
to Raymond working on him is opening without
the step you got one at the bench right there
Wallman with a shot where does he get this [__]
yeah outside well outside the line that was a
nice move by Mr Ned you gotta feel good about
that despair for Petrie and dalkovich out to
move it Orion Shea that was picked off inside
the Zone though there's a shot scores [Music]
makes it 1-1 it's a broken play
by Pittsburgh Around the Net
and a bucket Gets behind the dalkovich he
got a piece of it hirosi sets it up for him
hit the Blocker on the inside off the body
and into the back of the net and uh look what
I got wow Ned played it and actually Danielson
made the check that caused the loose Puck and
as he gets at this play the second period and we
get set to rejoin Ken Daniels and Mickey Redmond
Nate has always said his dream teammate would
have been the Pittsburgh clears it down cider
going back to retrieve it played all 82 games
last season five goals 42 points [Applause]
crank it shot knocked down never got
through here we go out of the box
names the hornet and a save made by Reimer
whether when they kill power plays they're going
to continue to click some of them 25 to 30 percent
because of the ability of penalty Killers to skate
Chase and Hound the puck they
just give you no time at all
to get much of anything done
marking again to gosses pair switches sides there
with cider gosper gets it back
now to break it again in front
beautifully set up to break it to Larkin and it's
two to one a five on three power play goal [Music]
ripping it past nadelkovic you can only
touched I think it touched Quran
stick on the way across as well
it's a good fake by gosh Despair and severe angle
Larkin's feet were behind the goal
line but not the Stick of the butt
I mean by Hayak saved by Reimer off the glass gets
knocked down by the Penguins anastroza reaches in
he gets pinned to the boards and freed up there
for Simon Edmondson moving up on the play James
saint ivany but Jonathan Peregrine's got it
nearly lost it got it back helped from Petrie
Peregrine Lawson again turned over in front of the
score won't be happy with that and
the Penguins capitalized to tie it
2-2 Houston has been in the middle of both
their goals well nice finish right there
they're going to change goaltenders Detroit
right now too it's halfway through the
second period and right before that comes
this bit of a turnover and a nice finish
for sure by the fin nice
finish no in pun intended right
so Reimer departs so Quran sets up
findsider now Costa Street [Applause]
spider to bring it to break it retrieves for
cider again for gosis there [Applause] [Music]
and he completely took away the sight line of
the goal Center in the dalkovich there for that
puck to find its place look at the pass here
by gosh despair right between the feet and a
one-timer by cider finds the back of the net from
almost back at the Blue Line no sight line for the
goalie on that one and most cider they're here
on 16 right now yeah I mean you gotta you gotta
have draft pick to be able to
rebuild your team over time
oh scores only sneak it in
short side on you and Bednar
wow that found its way through from Sam
poolan who is the 21st overall pick back
in 2019 was one of the Final Cuts at last
year's King uh tricky little severe angle
oh he had lots of room on that short side and I
mean lots of room yeah watches uh you can't see
it on this angle here but right in here there's a
lot of room with that left pad coming off the goal
post and he just banked it in off bednar's left
pad so that's an easy one for Pittsburgh to tie
it up at three Dimitri and Edmondson on defense
so the penguins have another lead [Applause]
so hard tied it they LED one nothing
came back again oh did that not to win
appreciate it third period underway Mickey
Redmond's gone downstairs uh between the
benches you'll know he missed all of last season
with the Red Wings twice with Achilles tears
and uh just too bad never got the suit
up for a game in Detroit and now he's
out long term the Penguins say again with
Pittsburgh too bad for Mark Preston shot
scores [Applause] three Detroit well you
see this deflection on replay holy mackerel
[Applause]
this is a major change of Direction on the puck
that just completely fools last uh madilkovic
rather they're gonna say this is icing but time
will expire this game is over and the Red Wings
Nick Win It by a final score of four to three yeah